Welcome back.
It's good to be lecturing again.
Uh so
last time we had a lecture was Monday
and
unfortunately the the the quality was
kind of poor and I'm not sure people got
a lot out of the lecture because of the
the poor quality.
So thankfully it was our pause for
breath day so so we weren't uh
necessarily covering anything of vital
importance. A lot of it was
like me answering questions from the
start of course survey, that kind of
thing.
But but I thought we would just hit the
highlights of the
the more important things that we did
talk about on Monday just to make sure
that that
that everybody got them.
So
we wrapped up our discussion of these
strongly consistent replication
protocols,
primary backup replication and chain
replication.
Uh so
uh
these strongly consistent replication
protocols
we observe
that
they work by
establishing some sort of total order
on operations.
So primary backup replication we saw
Let's do three. We could have three
backups.
And a primary and the way that it works
as we discussed before is that the
primary or clients rather talk to the
primary.
The primary talks to all of the backups,
sends a broadcast to all the backups.
Those backups respond to the primary.
And the primary then acknowledges the
client. And this is the point right here
at which uh at which the right commits.
So, this is the right path.
And the read path is that the client
just talks to the primary.
So, we said that this provides some
degree
of fault tolerance, right?
And the fault tolerance that it provides
is that if a replica crashes, another
replica can take over for it. So, if a
backup crashes, uh we can just bring up
another backup
uh
um by cloning the primary and having
that backup
replace it. Uh if the primary crashes,
then
then we have to um
uh we have to be careful, right? Because
we want to make sure that uh um that we
don't have that we're not picking up any
rights from the future, right? If we
clone one of the backups, the backup
might have rights on it that that
that that the client didn't
get acknowledged. Uh so so, recovering
from a primary crash is a little bit
harder, but still possible. Um but
ultimately, we have to have some sort of
coordinator
node that
is responsible for making sure that
well, it's responsible for for knowing
who's up at any given time, and it's
responsible for knowing which which
roles those nodes are playing, and for
telling the client who they should be
talking to, who is serving in the role
of the primary. So, there's some state
saved on this coordinator right now, and
the coordinator keeps track of who is
the primary, who are the backups.
Um in the case of chain replication,
if we have the client,
we have a head. Let's say that we have
um
uh
say two in the middle
and a tail.
So, the exact number of nodes in the
chain is
uh is is not important. Uh just like
with primary backup, uh it's it's not
important. There's I often draw these
diagrams with a specific number, but
don't get hung up on that.
Um so, in this case, um
the client's going to read uh from the
head.
The head is going to
uh or excuse me, the client's going to
write to the head.
The head is going to forward that
message on.
And the tail is going to acknowledge the
client.
This is the commit point right here
for chain replication.
And then
reads are going to happen
to the tail.
And so, here again, you have to have
some sort of coordinator.
Who's responsible for
knowing when processes fail, perhaps by
sending them a ping periodically and
seeing if they respond to it, and then
uh
declaring that they're they failed if it
doesn't uh hear back.
Uh and then it also has to know who's
playing what role at a given time, and
making sure that the client knows who
the head and the tail are. So, the
client knows who to contact for reads
and writes.
Um so, what we what we talked about at
the end of of last time is the fact that
this this coordinator is is really a a a
single point of failure, right? If we
just have one coordinator process here,
if the coordinator fails,
uh everything falls apart. So, so what
do we do? Well,
what you really have to do
is have some sort of replication of the
coordinator.
Also.
And so
in so doing you have these three
processes that behave as though they're
a single process. And then you get some
fault tolerance for the coordinator. So
these processes you have you you have
it's still not great when they fail,
right? But uh but you have some rules
that you can follow if one of them
crashes. Uh with the coordinator um
you really don't want the coordinator to
crash. So instead uh instead of having a
single coordinator process
uh you have to do something like having
some collection of processes that you
hope behave as one process. Somebody's
asking if this is expensive and slow.
Well, yeah. So if you want strong
consistency
you ultimately have to rely on something
that is going to make these coordinator
processes behave as though they're one
process.
So this is again, this is if you want
strong consistency.
So
this might be one reason why you might
want to avoid having strong consistency,
right? Uh strong consistency isn't
always the best choice.
Uh so how do we ensure that these three
processes actually behave like they are
the same process? And that that leads us
into the next topic
that we're going to begin discussing
today, which is
uh which is which is consensus.
So
and it's interesting. I talked about
this a little bit on Monday, but when
you look at the chain replication paper
um they they state an assumption. They
say, "We assume the coordinator doesn't
fail."
And then they uh
they admit that that's an unrealistic
assumption and they explain that in the
actual implementation that they have um
they do instead have a group of
coordinator process like that processes
like this that are running a consensus
protocol among them to make sure that
they are agreement in agreement with one
another.
So,
there are times when you really do need
consensus.
Um so, let's start to talk about those.
Okay. So,
one is
you have a bunch of processes
and you need to make sure that they all
deliver some the same messages in the
same order.
Actually, all of the examples that I
have are going to start with you have a
bunch of processes. So, let's let's
write that up here.
Okay, so that's one situation.
Here's another.
You have a bunch of processes
and you need them all to keep track of
which processes exist.
You need them all to keep a list of
which processes exist and whenever
anyone dies or leaves for whatever
reason, everyone's list has to get
updated.
So, we'll say you need them all to know
which processes
exist
and
are running.
Okay.
Here's another one.
You have a bunch of processes
and you want one process to play a
particular distinguished role and you
want to let every process know about it.
So, you have a bunch of processes and
you want one process to play a
distinguished role.
And you want other processes to know
about it.
Here's another one.
You have a bunch of processes
and you want them
to take turns
getting
mutually exclusive access
to some resource.
Like a file or something.
Here's another situation.
You have a bunch of processes and
they're all participating in a
transaction
of some kind.
And you need them to agree on whether
the transaction is committed or about or
aborted.
So it turns out that these are all
classic distributed systems problems.
And they have names.
So this first one
is called the totally ordered broadcast
problem.
Also called atomic broadcast.
So we'll call it totally ordered
broadcast.
The second one you need you need to know
uh which you need all the processes to
know which other processes exist and are
running. Um
this is called the the group membership
problem.
And if they can fail then it's also
called the failure detection problem.
Uh number three
is called the leader election problem.
So, let's see.
I don't have a lot of room, but I'll
write group membership here.
Failure detection.
This is leader election.
Number four
you want them to take turns getting
access, mutually exclusive access to
some resource. Um this is the
distributed mutual exclusion problem.
And this last one
they're all participating in transaction
and you need them to agree on whether
it's committed or aborted. Uh this is
the distributed transaction commit
problem.
So,
what do all these problems have in
common?
What would you say they all have in
Okay, so someone in Slack says they can
all be solved by implementing consensus.
So we do say, yeah, when do you need
consensus? But But uh okay.
So But they all Why Why do you need
consensus? Well, they all involve this
bunch of processes trying to coordinate
with one another
and reach agreement about something. So
the thing they're trying to agree on
could vary, right?
They could be trying to agree agree on
the order to deliver messages in.
Right? That's what totally ordered
broadcast is about. They could be trying
to agree on whether or not a process has
failed. You have to do that for failure
detection. They could be trying to agree
on who who the leader is
uh in leader election. They could be
trying to agree on who currently gets
access to a shared resource.
That's what the distributed mutual
exclusion problem does. Or they could be
trying to agree on whether or not to
commit a transaction.
So the details vary.
But all of these are going to boil down
to the consensus problem, which is the
problem of getting a group of processes
to coordinate and agree on something.
So So let's try to formally define the
consensus problem.
And I should point out that what makes
this hard in distributed systems is
faults.
So crash faults and omission faults are
the ones that we're going to be
considering. In fact, mostly just crash
faults because it's really hard. It's
hard enough even then, even just in the
case of crash faults.
Okay.
So
this problem of getting processes to
agree.
Oh, somebody has to see this again.
This is distributed transaction commit
down here.
Okay.
So, we we have some processes. We want
to get them to agree. And to make things
simple, let's say that the thing that
they're trying to agree on is just one
bit, zero or one.
So, every process gets to have a say,
and every process gets to contribute one
bit, zero or one. So, we can draw a box
like this.
So, this box implements consensus.
And here are the processes that are
inputs to it.
So, we're going to say every process has
to
uh gets to contribute a bit. And let's
say the bits happen to be zero, one, and
zero.
The consensus problem is to design a
protocol so that everybody comes out
agreeing on a value.
So,
it could be this,
or it could be this.
So, you might look at this and think,
"Oh, well, that's easy, right?" Zero is
the majority, so just go with zero. Or
if one had been the majority, just go
with one.
Uh and indeed this notion of majority is
going to be important. Uh
but what you have to keep it in mind is
that
there isn't some external process that
looks at these numbers and makes the
choice. Rather, it's these three
processes coming in without any
knowledge of what number the other ones
picked that have to coordinate among
themselves and reach a point where they
all agree. And they have to do it in the
presence of failure and asynchrony.
So, we're going to talk about uh
one of the best-known algorithms for
consensus. But before we do, um I want
to start to talk about the properties
that consensus algorithms try to
satisfy.
Um so, the first of these properties is
termination.
Let's start a new page for this,
actually.
So, termination.
This says that each correct process
eventually decides on a value.
So if termination holds, then you're
eventually going to get something out of
this consensus box on every line.
Note that we haven't even said that what
you get on every line is the same yet,
just that you get something. So that's
what termination gives you. Termination
says
that eventually you're going to get
something on every line.
Well, then you also have
agreement.
So this says that
all correct processes
agree
on the same value.
So if anybody outputs a zero, then they
all do.
And if anyone outputs a one, then they
So let's imagine for a moment that this
was it. Imagine that these were the only
two properties that we had to satisfy.
If these were the two properties that we
had to satisfy in order for it to be a a
consensus algorithm,
then what could we do to implement
consensus that would be really really
simple?
Make all the processes crash.
Well, okay.
That's a fair answer. That wasn't
actually the answer that I was
expecting. Um
Okay, let's let's suppose that the um
other than that.
Uh
Okay, so how would we implement
consensus? How would we make them all
agree on the value on a value if these
are if these are the only two properties
that we have to satisfy?
Yeah, okay. So, there's some good
suggestions. Um one person says just
choose the first value or somebody else
says
have a default value and not care about
the input. Yeah. So, yeah, you could
just say have everybody output zero,
ignore the input or have everyone output
one. There, consensus solved.
Well, we can't do that. So, we have to
have a third property. Um
This is called I'm going to call it
validity.
Uh but sometimes it goes by other names.
Uh some people call it
integrity.
Some people call it non-triviality.
Um but I'm going to call it validity.
Validity just says
the agreed upon value
must be
one of the proposed values.
So, that rules out the possibility of
just ignoring the input and always
outputting the same thing and claiming
to have solved consensus then. Okay. So,
termination, agreement, validity.
I said that consensus algorithms try to
satisfy these properties. Um
but it turns out no consensus algorithm
actually does satisfy them all, at least
not in the asynchronous network model.
Does anyone know why no consensus
algorithm actually satisfies all three
of these?
So, the short answer is
because it's impossible.
This is the famous uh FLP result, what's
known as the FLP result in distributed
systems. It's called FLP uh because it
was proved uh by
Michael Fischer,
Nancy Lynch,
and Michael Patterson.
So, those are their initials, FLP.
Uh
this came from
their 1983 paper.
So, it says that you can't have all of
these properties be true
uh in the asynchronous network model and
the crash fault model.
So, if crashes can occur
and messages are asynchronous,
uh you can't have all this be true. The
paper is called impossibility of
distributed consensus with one faulty
process.
Uh so, it turns out you always have to
compromise on one of these things.
Which one do you think we're going to
compromise on? Yes, there's a
mathematical proof for it. Uh and I
encourage you to check out the paper if
you want to see the proof.
Um so, if you have to compromise on one
of these properties, which one do you
think you're going to compromise on?
Validity. Well, that's an interesting
suggestion. Okay, so, instead of it
going to all the trouble to implement a
uh
the consensus algorithm, uh we could
just say,
"Okay, um
the agreed upon value is it's five."
But, I'm not sure that that would um be
very useful, right? It would solve the
problem,
but uh it would solve the consensus
problem that we wrote down, right? But,
it wouldn't necessarily help you get
anything done.
Okay, somebody else suggested agreement.
Okay, well, if you compromise on
agreement, then
Okay, but then then you don't then you
don't have consensus, right? Then then
you're back where you started, right?
Because if you compromise on agreement,
then looking back at this picture, you
started with 010. If you compromise on
agreement, then maybe you'll come out
with 010, also.
So,
compromising on agreement doesn't seem
great.
That only leaves one possibility, right?
Have to compromise on termination.
So, we can have a consensus algorithm,
but it doesn't necessarily terminate.
So,
with termination
compromised,
it means that
if you get a response
on all the processes, then it's going to
be the same, right? We have agreement.
And we also know that the response we
get is going to be one of the initial
values, cuz we have validity. But, it's
also possible that we just won't get an
answer at all, right? This could happen.
So, non-termination could happen, and we
have to be okay with that. And if a run
of the consensus protocol doesn't
terminate, at some point, we have to
shrug and say,
"Okay, it's not terminating. Let's try
again."
And of course, that run might not
terminate, either.
Okay.
So, with that
I think we're almost ready to start
talking about an actual consensus
algorithm.
Um let's do a quiz question first.
So, before we do the quiz question, uh
let's talk about the
the last couple of quiz questions. Um I
can't remember if we talked about the um
uh
answer to quiz number 12 yet. Uh
if we talked about it on Monday or not.
Um anyway, what it uh
the the question here was what does it
mean for a replicated storage system to
be strongly consistent? And the the
answer we were looking for here is
informally what it means is that uh
clients can't tell that the data is
replicated.
So, for quiz number 13
we we said this is about uh chain
replication versus primary backup. So,
we said throughput if throughput is
number of actions completed per unit of
time, when does chain replication
provide better write throughput than
primary backup replication? Uh so, the
answer here was if you have a mix
of writes and reads. Because if you just
had if you just had writes
uh then they're all going to be hitting
the head node. If you just had reads,
they're all going to be hitting the tail
node. So, then there's no uh uh
advantage to using chain replication
versus primary backup. So, you have to
have a mix of reads and writes.
Uh and furthermore, the particular mix
of reads and writes that seems to be
most advantageous for chain replication
is if you have about 10 or 15% writes
and the rest reads. And that's what the
uh empirical evaluation in the chain
replication paper bears out. So, those
are the circumstances when chain
replication provides better write
throughput. When your balance of writes
and reads is 10 or 15% writes and the
rest reads. That's what we were looking
for there.
All right. On to today's quiz question.
And the form should be open. I will send
out the link.
We'll wait a couple more minutes.
All right, let's move on.
Uh somebody asked uh
what's the difference between
termination and validity? So,
So, here's an example of a violation of
validity.
If you get some inputs, say
1 1 0.
Or even if let's just say even if we're
only dealing with bits, let's say all
the possibilities are uh the only
possibilities are one and zero. Um
so, let's say all the inputs are one
and the output is zero.
This would be a validity violation.
Um
a termination violation
would be
if some or all of the
processes just don't ever
uh agree upon just don't ever have an
answer at all.
All right.
So, I think we're ready now to start
talking about uh an actual consensus
algorithm.
Paxos.
So,
Paxos is a consensus algorithm uh
invented by Leslie Lamport.
Uh he first tried to publish it in 1990,
but it took eight years for anyone to
publish the paper.
And in the original paper that he that
he wrote about it, he used an analogy to
parliamentary procedure with laws and
voting and ballots.
And to this day, some people use that
terminology to explain Paxos.
Others don't.
So, I'm going to avoid the laws and
voting and ballots terminology, and I'm
going to stick mostly to the terminology
that he adopted later
uh in a paper called Paxos Made Simple,
uh which came out in 2001.
So,
Paxos is really not just one algorithm,
uh but it's a family of algorithms,
meaning there are many variants of it,
or flavors of it. And we're just going
to talk about boring vanilla Paxos for
now.
Um so, in Paxos, there are three roles
that a process can play.
Proposer,
acceptor,
and learner.
So, proposers propose values.
Acceptors
actually choose from the proposed values
or contribute to choosing from the
proposed values.
And learners learn the agreed upon
value.
So one thing to point out is that in
practice
a single node might take on multiple
roles or even all of them. So one
process in might be all three of
proposer, acceptor, and learner.
But when you're learning Paxos, it's
easiest to talk about the roles
separately.
So
we'll call any node that plays any role
a Paxos node.
And when we draw Lamport diagrams of
runs of Paxos,
we're going to have particular processes
and we're going to say, "Okay, this
process is the proposer, this process is
the acceptor, this process is the
learner." and so on.
But in practice, there might be one
machine
that's actually playing multiple roles.
One thing that Paxos nodes, any node
that's playing any role, one thing that
they have to know is how many acceptors,
a majority of acceptors is. So for
example, if there are three acceptors, a
majority of acceptors is two.
If there are five, a majority is three.
So all the nodes have to know how many
is a majority. That's a fact that they
have to know in advance. So that
information needs to have gotten to them
somehow before the algorithm runs.
Another thing is that Paxos nodes have
to be able to persist data so they don't
forget what they accepted.
And then one other thing to keep in mind
here is that the protocol that we're
looking at is for deciding on a single
value.
So if you want to decide on a sequence
of values, which is a common thing to
want to do, then you have to run the
protocol again.
And there's more to say about that, and
there's optimizations that you can do
then, but we're not going to talk about
that yet. We're just going to talk about
a protocol for deciding on one value.
Okay, so let's look at an actual run of
the algorithm.
And I'm going to start a new page
because we're going to need all the room
we can get.
So for simplicity, uh let's say that
there's one proposer,
and I'll call her P1.
Um and let's say there's three acceptors
and two learners.
So in this case, uh what would uh
what would a majority of acceptors be?
That's right, yeah. A majority would be
two.
Okay. So,
let's say that our proposer P1 wants to
propose a value.
So the first thing that it has to do is
send what's called a prepare message to
a majority, at least at least a majority
of acceptors.
So,
it's going to send a message that's
called prepare,
and that message is going to come along
with what it calls the proposal number.
The proposal number has to be unique.
So, no one else can use it. So, if you
had multiple proposers, you might
establish rules in advance. Like, if you
had two proposers, maybe you would say
that one proposer could only use
odd-numbered proposal numbers, and the
other one could only use even-numbered
proposal numbers. That has to be
established in advance.
Something else about the proposal number
is it also has to be higher than any
that the that the proposer has tried
before.
So, it has to be able to store the
proposal numbers it's used and make sure
not to reuse them.
So, we're going to say that proposer one
sends a a prepare message with a
proposal number. Let's say that the
proposal number is five.
And it's going to send it to a majority
of acceptors.
So, we'll say this message is
prepare
five.
And let's say that it gets sent to
acceptor one and acceptor two.
When an acceptor gets a prepare message,
it looks at that number, that proposal
number, and it does this check.
Did I previously promise to ignore
requests with this proposal number?
If it did, then it ignores it.
If no,
it now promises to ignore any request
that has a proposal number lower than
that.
So, it replies
to the proposer with a promise message.
So, in this case, it's going to be
promise five.
So, a promise of n means I will ignore
any request with a proposal number
lower than n.
We're going to come have to come back
and talk about this more later. Uh but
this is for for today, this is what
we'll say.
Okay.
So, let's say that that
proposer one sends prepare five to these
two acceptors, a1 and a2, and suppose
they both respond with five.
So, now we've gotten a a majority of our
acceptors to promise five. So, keep in
mind, five is only the proposal number.
It's not the value that we're deciding
on. It's just a proposal number.
But at this point, we've sort of reached
a milestone. Because now that now that a
majority of acceptors have promised
five, now there can never be a majority
that promise four or anything less than
five.
A minority might still promise four, but
it's going to going to be impossible for
a majority to do so.
Because
with this promise, they're saying from
now on, I'm going to ignore any request
that has a lower proposal number.
Okay.
Back to the proposer.
Now that the proposer has received
promise messages from a majority of of
acceptors,
it can now send what's called an accept
message uh to a majority of acceptors.
And the accept message is going to have
the proposal number that was promised
and the actual value that it wants to
propose.
This is something else that we're going
to have to come back to. I'm do I'm I'm
giving you the simple version now.
So,
it's going to send an accept message.
Let's say, again, for simplicity's sake,
that it talks to the same two acceptors.
And the accept message
is going to have the proposal number,
that's five
in this case.
And then there's the actual value that
we're proposing,
which we haven't started to talk about
yet. Let's say that the value we're
proposing is zero.
So our accept message will be accept 5
0, and we'll send it to a majority of
acceptors, at least a majority of
acceptors.
We'll just say that they happen to be
the same ones we've been talking to so
far.
Now what? Well,
the acceptors get the accept message.
When an acceptor gets an accept
message
with a proposal number and a value,
it's going to ask itself,
"Did I previously promise to ignore
requests with this proposal number?"
If so, it ignores it.
If no,
it did not promise to ignore those
requests,
then it replies
with
accepted
and the proposal number and the value.
And it also
sends that accepted message to all the
learners.
So the point
when a majority of acceptors send these
accepted messages for a particular
proposal number and a particular value
is the point when consensus is reached.
So, where is that point?
So, right here is the point where they
send those messages.
So, the consensus is on the value zero.
It's not actually necessarily on the
proposal number, but from this point
onward
in this run of Paxos, we have consensus
on the value. And notice that not
everyone knows it yet.
In particular, it's the point at which
these messages these two messages from
the acceptors to the proposal the the
proposer are sent that consensus is
reached.
So, the proposer doesn't even know yet.
And the acceptors don't know about the
other acceptor, right? And the learners
certainly don't know yet.
Uh
so, not everybody knows that consensus
has been reached, but it has at this
point.
So,
at the point finally when a proposer
or a learner gets accepted
messages from a majority of acceptors
for a particular
proposal number
then they know that consensus has been
reached on the value that goes with the
proposal
that it goes with that proposal number.
So, it's right here
that proposer one has learned that
consensus has been reached.
And of course, it's right here and right
here that these learners know that
consensus has has been reached. So,
there's a difference between the moment
at which consensus is reached and the
moment at which everybody finds out that
that's the case.
So, there's a couple of places where I
said
uh I was I was simplifying things.
And those we're going to have to go back
and patch up because what we actually do
in those cases is more subtle than what
I described here.
Um but rather than going through that
right now, um
we'll talk about that more
uh next time when we talk about having
more than one proposer.
And we'll also talk about fault
tolerance next time
uh because that's what makes things more
interesting.
Hopefully, we'll also have time to talk
about why the algorithm isn't guaranteed
to terminate. Uh so, we do have validity
here and we do have agreement, but we
don't have termination. So, we'll talk
about uh uh why that's the case.
All right, I'm looking back at chat for
questions.
So, one person asked uh
if a previous value is one, all future
values have to be greater than one or
can it be zero? So, one important thing
to distinguish between is difference
between a proposal number and the value
being agreed upon. So, here five was the
proposal number and zero was the value
being agreed upon. Zero was just a value
uh that I chose, right? I could have
also picked one um or I could have
picked uh the string cat or I could have
picked something else. Um
that uh
that's kind of uh irrelevant here. It's
just it in this case we're saying
in keeping with the earlier example
where we had to agree on one bit. I
decided to make it zero, but it also
could have been something else.
Um
the proposal number is what has to go up
over time. So, a given proposer
when it sends a particular proposal
number,
not only has does it have to be unique,
um but it also has to be higher than any
that that proposer has tried before.
Um so, if this proposer were to send out
a new proposal at this point, let's say
that this proposer is using odd numbers,
then it would have to send a prepare
seven message.
So, somebody asked how
when do acceptors or how do acceptors
find out that consensus is reached?
Yeah, okay, good question. So, when I
said earlier that um in practice a
single node could take on multiple roles
or even all of the roles,
your acceptor nodes might also be
playing learner roles.
So, learners are
nodes that learn the agreed upon value,
right? In practice, acceptors might be
learners, too. It's just easier to draw
this picture if we have distinct
processes here. But in practice, a given
node might be playing the acceptor role
and might also be playing the learner
role. So, that's how it would find out
that consensus had been reached because
it was playing the learner role, and
then it would be getting these learner
messages.
So, if you want a node to be able to
find out about the agreed upon value,
then it had better be a learner.
Same goes for So, this proposer is going
to receive accepted messages from the
majority of acceptors, but if you had
some other proposer somewhere, if you
wanted that proposer to find out about
the the agreed-upon value, if there was
an agreed-upon value, then that node had
better actually be playing the learner
role as well.
Other questions?
Okay.
So, I want to try to write down the
steps of the algorithm
with an asterisk for those
simplifications that we made.
So, we said
when an acceptor
gets a
gets a prepare in message
it asks
did I previously promise
to ignore
requests
with this proposal number.
If yes, it ignores it.
If no,
it now promises
to ignore
any request
with a proposal number lower than n.
And it replies to the proposer. Oops.
with a promise n
message.
I'm going to put an asterisk here,
meaning we'll have to come back and talk
about this.
Because it's actually a little bit more
subtle than this.
And then the other rule that we wrote
down,
once a proposer
has received
promise messages
for a particular proposal number,
let's say N,
from a majority of acceptors,
it sends
an accept
message
to majority of acceptors,
where N here is the proposal number that
was promised.
And val
is the actual
value it wants to propose.
And I'm going to put two asterisks here
cuz we have to come back to this, too.
next time.
All right.
So, we're about out of time for today.
You might be wondering
why this algorithm why this is so
complicated, right?
And part of the reason it's so
complicated is because it has to be
tolerant of failure.
So, we'll start to talk about that next
time. We'll start to talk about
what happens
uh when processes in this out that are
part of this algorithm fail.
Uh somebody wanted to see this page
again. Sure.
Mhm.
All right.
That's it for today.
Next time we're going to come back and
talk about failure, why this algorithm
isn't guaranteed to terminate, and
about what to do if you want to agree on
a sequence of values instead of just one
value. See you next time.